I want you to travel back in time with
me to the before time to 2017 I don't
know if you can remember it dinosaurs
were roaming the earth I was a security
researcher I had spent about 5 or 6
years doing research on the ways in
which apts which is short for advanced
persistent threats which stands for
nation-state actors spy on journalists
and activists and lawyers and scientists
and just generally people who speak
truth to power and I'd been doing this
for a while when I discovered that one
of my fellow researchers with whom I had
been doing this all this time was
allegedly a serial rapist so the first
thing that I did was I read a bunch of
articles about this and I in January of
2018 I read an article with some of his
alleged victims and one of the things
that really struck me about this article
is how scared they were they were really
frightened they had you know tape over
the cameras on their phones and on their
laptops and what they were worried about
was that he was a hacker and he was
going to hack into their stuff and he
was going to ruin their lives I and this
had kept them silent for a really long
time so I was furious and I didn't want
anyone to ever feel that way again so I
did what I usually do when I'm angry I
tweeted
and the thing that I tweeted was that if
you are a woman who has been sexually
abused by a hacker and that hacker has
threatened to break into your devices
that you could contact me and I would
try to make sure that your device got a
full sort of forensic look over and then
I went to lunch
ten thousand retweets later I had
accidentally started a project so every
morning I woke up and my mailbox was
full it was full of the stories of men
and women telling me the worst thing
that had ever happened to them I was
contacted by women who were being spied
on by men by men who were being spied on
by men by women who were being spied on
by women but the vast majority of the
people contacted me were women who had
been sexually abused by men who were now
spying on them
the one particularly interesting case
involved a man who came to me because
his boyfriend had outed him as gay to
his extremely conservative Korean family
so this is this is not just a men spying
on on women issue and I'm here to share
what I learned from this experience what
I learned is that data leaks it's like
water
it gets in places you don't want it
human leaks your friends give away
information about you your family gives
away information about you you go to a
party somebody tags you as having been
there and this is one of the ways in
which abusers pick up information about
you that you don't otherwise want them
to know it is not uncommon for abusers
to go to friends and family and ask for
information about their victims under
the guise of being concerned about their
mental health a form of of leak that I
saw was actually what we call a count
Kampf
so your Gmail account your Twitter
account your Instagram account your
iCloud your Apple ID your Netflix your
tick-tock I had to figure out what a
chick talk was and if it had a login
I saw it compromised and the reason for
that is because your abuser is not
always your abuser it is really common
for people in relationships to share
passwords furthermore people who are
intimate who know a lot about each other
could guess each other's security
questions or they can look over each
other's shoulders to see what code
they're using in order to lock their
phones they frequently have physical
access to the phone or they have
physical access to the laptop I and this
gives them a lot of opportunity to to do
things to people's accounts which is
very dangerous the good news is that we
have advice for people to lock down
their accounts this advice already
exists and it comes down to this
use strong unique passwords for all of
your accounts use more strong unique
passwords as the answers to your
security questions so that somebody who
knows the name of your childhood pet
can't reset your password and finally
turn on the highest level of two-factor
authentication that you are comfortable
using so that even if an abuser manages
to steal your password because they
don't have the second factor they will
not be able to log into your account the
other thing that you should do is you
should take a look at the security and
privacy tabs for most of your accounts
most accounts have a security or privacy
tab that tells you what devices are
logging in and it tells you where
they're logging in from for example here
I am logging into Facebook from the
LaQuinta where we are having this
meeting and if for example I took a look
at my facebook logins and I saw somebody
logging in from Dubai I would find that
suspicious because
I have not been to Dubai in some time
but sometimes it really is a rat
if by rat you mean remote access tool
and remote access tool is essentially
what we mean when we say stalker where
so one of the reasons why getting full
access to your device is really tempting
for governments is the same reason why
getting full access to your device is
tempting for for abusive partners and
former partners we carry tracking
devices around in our pockets all day
long
we carry devices that contain all of our
passwords all of our communications
including our end-to-end encrypted
communications all of our emails all of
our contacts all of our selfies are all
in one place often our financial
information is also in this place and so
full access to a person's phone is the
next best thing to full access to a
person's mind and what stalker wear does
is it gives you this access so you may
ask how does it work
the way in which stalker wear works is
that it's a commercially available
program which and abuser purchases
installs on the device that they want to
spy on usually because they have
physical access so they can trick the
their target into installing it
themselves by saying you know this is a
very important program you should
install on your on your device and then
they paid the stalker wear company for
access to a portal which gives them all
of the information from that device
you're usually paying something like 40
bucks a month so this kind of spying is
remarkably cheap do these companies know
that they're that their tools are being
used as tools of abuse absolutely if you
take a look at the marketing copy for
cocoa spy which is one of these products
it says
right there on the website that cocoa
spy allows you to spy on your wife with
ease you don't have to worry about where
she goes who she talks to or what
websites she visits so that's creepy
hello spy which is another such product
had a marketing page in which they spent
most of their coffee talking about the
prevalence of cheating and how important
it is to catch your partner cheating
including this fine picture of a man who
has clearly just caught his partner
cheating and has beaten her she has a
black eye there is blood on her face and
I don't think that there is really a lot
of a lot of question about whose side
hello spy is on in this particular case
and who they're trying to sell their
product to it turns out that if you have
a stalker where on your computer or on
your phone it can be really difficult to
know whether or not it's there and one
of the reasons for that is because
antivirus companies often don't don't
recognize stalker where as malicious
they don't recognize it as a as a trojan
or as any of the other stuff that you
would normally find that they would warn
you about these are some results from
earlier this year from virustotal
I think that for for one sample that I
looked at I had something like a result
of seven out of sixty of the platforms
recognized the stalker wear that I was
testing and here is another one where I
managed to get 10 10 out of 61 so this
is still some some very very bad results
I have managed to convince a couple of
antivirus companies to start marking
stalker where as malicious so that all
you have to do if you're worried about
having this stuff on your on your
computer is you download the program you
run a scan and it tells you hey there's
some potentially unwanted program on
your device it gives you the option of
removing it but it does not remove it
automatically and one of the reasons for
that is because of the way that abuse
works frequently victims of abuse aren't
sure
or whether or not they want to tip off
their abuser by cutting off their access
or they're worried that their abuser is
going to escalate to violence or perhaps
even greater violence than they've
already been engaging in Kaspersky was
one of the very first companies that
that said that they were going to start
taking this seriously and in November of
this year they issued a report in which
they said that since they started
tracking stalker wear among their users
that they had seen an increase of 35%
likewise
lookout came out with a statement saying
that they were going to take this much
more seriously and finally a company
called malwarebytes also put out such a
statement and said that they had found
2,500 programs in the time that they had
been looking which could be classified
as stalker we're finally in November I
helped to launch a coalition called the
coalition against stalker we're made up
of academics people who are doing this
this sort of thing on the ground the you
know practitioners of helping people to
escape from intimate partner violence I
and antivirus companies and our goal is
both to educate people about about these
programs but also to convince the
antivirus companies to change the norm
in how they act around this very scary
software so that soon if I get up in
front of you and I talk to you about
this next year I can tell you that the
problem has been solved and all you have
to do is download any antivirus and it
is considered normal for it to detect
stalker where that is my hope thank you
very much
[Applause]